let me tell you something right outside
of the stadium in legion
just as the players leave the locker
room it says just win
baby the famous mantra from al davis and
that's what fans want to happen they're
hoping for it each and every week
rocky theis is with some die hard raider
nation faithful rocky yeah diehard
raiders fans right
hey yes die hard is right right you guys
die hard nerds
we are die hard great or fans
i have to admit you guys know obviously
fans cannot go inside the stadium but
the energy outside the stadium is crazy
you guys have really brought it
raider nation to vegas yes we did raider
nation
introduce yourselves marlena
isaac isaac nathan cameron jeremiah
luciano
richard richard okay this is the family
i chose because they are all here
celebrating and i have to say
i love that this is a family event for
you why is that
because it brings the family together
and that's what we enjoy and we enjoy
seeing other families as well come
together for
the raiders is that what the raiders is
all about family
it's all about family you know it's from
from the bay to l.a to vegas
with community and this is one nation
this is how we do it it's raider for
life and we bleed
silver and black all day i love that
passion i love that passion
so how do you guys feel about the
raiders being in vegas what does it
bring to
our city it brings love and enjoyment
because everybody's coming
and we're just happy and that the
raiders came because
usually we can't go to a stadium because
like as long as we could watch on tv
when they're playing
absolutely i love that so if you guys
could talk to the raiders players
all right if you could talk to them what
would you say i'm gonna start with you
baby i want them to win yeah what about
you
i'll say just wait for the las vegas
raiders
i love that okay last question last
question what makes
the proper raiders fan like if i if i
didn't know
what do i need to bring to the table
here oh man you just need to bring
love i enjoyment yeah raiders just
realized
and you got to be in case of models
because that's how we do it
vegas and this is raider country go
raiders
all right that's right i love it i will
send it back to you guys this is so much
fun thank you
thank you